歡迎收看趙華
我是趙華
我是阿倫
今天終於打腳了
那你打我幹嘛
打腳 確實打腳
因為昨天我們還在討論
因為昨天有下跌第一天
但今天盤中有跌到大概1000點
開盤就1000點
開盤啦 開盤就1000點
說實話有一點嚇一跳
怎麼搞的說來就來
沒錯 可是大家期待了打腳
終於開始在打了
不知道打完了沒啦
但是確實嘛
你這一次吉拉過程
大家一直在問說有沒有
第二次可以買的機會
所以這一次出現了
那我們等置跌
我覺得應該還是可以
去好好把握一下
因為一波的V轉
好多人都想說
好像反彈那麼快
我沒有辦法上車
但是市場就這麼有趣
像昨天晚上廢半
就跌了五個百分點
沒錯
然後講的事情
你會覺得之前不是就知道嗎
對啊
他們講說AI有相關
有九家大公司的隱藏的負債
有三兆美元
那現在這個市場利率
一直往上飆的話
這些債務將來就會爆破這樣子
比較貴嘛
對 好 講得那麼可怕
可是其實今天台股
還算是有強力的支撐
因為它下面拉了一支下影線
所以 好 我們來看一下喔
到底所謂的直利率
飆這件事情
為什麼跟AI連在一起
等一下會簡單的跟大家聊一下
好的 再來的話
不要忘記一件事情
每一次在上漲
就說我們台股啊
好多的元件在漲價啊
下跌就忘了嗎
沒吧 漲價還還是在發
所以等一下會講的是
公率元件
沒錯 這個我們等一下
來幫大家好好了解一下
這個我們先來快速的瞄一下
就是又有鬼故事了
那目前來說
左邊這邊呢
就是川普呢
直接發布了一張地圖
什麼地圖
就是呢 河姆斯海峽
就是美國的新領土
其實就一個重點
那個重點就是
美伊現在是談不攏的
然後目前已經進入下一個世代了
這個世代就是呢
我們可能也不會攻擊了
但是呢就會拖在這裡
但是油價上漲大家就是有通膨壓力
這同樣的還是看來對經濟市場有老亂
是
那不過呢昨天就是有一些
美債值利率的飆升嘛
跟這一個新聞
這新聞呢就是包含了九家
美國的九大家
就是什麼博通那些全部加進來
除了傳統的
我們在提的四大CSP大廠之外
周邊也都有加起來AMD等等的
這些加進來之後
他與相關AI的表外承諾
已經達到了三兆美元
那這個三兆美元
是不會放在他的財報裡面的
不會放在資產
他不會放在資產負債表
負助的裡面包含了
就是對於未來有幾家
譬如說可能像是
就四大家嘛
裡面有說他買能源
那已經買到2054年了
那這些東西呢
因為都還沒有開始算
所以都不用列進來
但實際上他們簽的那個約
是不管你AI發展好還是不好
你未來就是一定要付這筆簽
好 我也開始的租約
但已經給人家簽了
是的 而且簽就是簽很長
然後簽的金額又很大
那目前來說呢
整個這個是表內的
表內的負債2480
長期負債有3560億
那表外的呢
這邊就有9000億
那這裡呢
Total會有1.5兆
所以直接加一加
不不不 弄一弄就大概三兆左右
才夠承諾
是的 就是像可能
輝達要跟台積電 跟美光
或者說跟記憶體廠
要簽訂未來的長約
我們常常有聽到
美光簽長約 未來營收有保障
對不對 那這些錢要誰付
就是這一些大老傅
在搭配前一陣子
大家講 他的自由現金流
已經轉付了
所以可能很多要付出去的錢
將來是要借錢來給的
沒錯 他們沒有特別拿出來講的
這個金額已經大大的
大家的超過大家想像空間了
對 所以目前這個
整個AI的軍備競賽
如火如荼
那大家就覺得
這個是不是就要崩盤啦
泡沫啦 付不出來啦
不過目前我們台灣看起來還處在一個
你借就借吧
反正你膽要給我啦
反正我現在有拿到訂單的一個情況
只有個恐怖平衡的狀態
沒錯 那我這邊幫他
快速解釋一下
為什麼他們難道這一些CEO
會不知道錢燒成這樣子
不會擔心嗎
他們能夠做到這個大公司的CEO
可是他們現在其實更在意的是
未來誰是AI的領頭央
只要我能拿到霸主的地位
這些錢我都賺得回來
邏輯就是這樣
所以他們現在頭洗下去了
你洗到一半
你要泡泡洗乾淨
所以他們現在洗到一半
頭都還是泡泡
那你只能一直向下洗
那向下洗大家就要砸錢
所以找到未來
一定有一天
那個龍頭會出現
所以現在大家
至少這四大家都想當龍頭
他不在意現在我會不會虧錢
對 所以這場戲
應該還要再看一陣子
那我覺得對於台廠來講
應該就是好事
是你們搶吧
對 你們搶
反正都要跟我們要
OK 好 再來呢
美債直率最近
這個走得非常
30年級創下了
30年級的美債
創下了一個
19年來的新高
是 體力率
沒錯 那這個直率
又跟之前修正的時候
迎來的一個話題是一樣的
就是科技股的孤紙修正
跟科技股
跟股市的資金排擠效應
而且現在大家也擔心
好像很久沒人提了
美國的財政赤字
它不停的發新環就
這個新的會越來越貴
沒錯
後來要還的錢
跟剛剛其實也不是一樣
要還不完
我們單看這個數據
我覺得美國不太可能升息
雖然合理通膨要抗通膨要升息
可是呢
如果你再繼續升息
這個數字只會越來越高
對 那現在有一些資金的幾對效應
所以帶動它的質疑率去拉高
那你這個時候
我覺得升息的基因會降得更低
對 那為什麼
整個還是很重要
因為美債質疑率
是一個全球資產定價的定毛持之一
那再來對科技股的影響呢
就是我今天只要防災美債
美國又不會倒
對 我就領個快6%的利息
對 年化嘛
那可是我這個買股票
我7月如果跌 這樣跌個40%
那我乾脆把錢都
一部分的資金拿來放美債
反正這是無風險的報酬
所以到時候可能AI也
即便有AI發展
還是會比較辛苦
剛剛講到一些
可能大家關注的一些總經力空
我們來講一些產業力多
CoreOS爆單外易
那台積電又是台積電
所以目前看起來
我們的產業面這一塊
應該還是沒什麼問題的
所以這也代表說
像今天為什麼一開盤
有受到美股影響殺下去
那後來我們也隨即有拉一個腳
就是回到我們的基本面
或是我們的接單狀況
是 還是受益的
沒錯 我們來看一下
AI需求擴大
GPU加ASIC同步放量
CoreOS不能只在靠MVD
Google AMD這一些
都同步去擴大晶片的佈局
那再來後段的瓶頸浮現
前段出很快
但是後段的封裝跟不上
所以英特爾馬來西亞廠
會協力去做資源
那再來另外一個
就是Covos會成為新的護城河
相關的不能只看製程
還有GPU ASIC HPM
先進封裝
基本上就一條龍
所以這些都是什麼
這些都是未來
選股票的這個邏輯
那從Covos的擴產
到先進到封裝的設備
到測試的設備
到一些探診卡
然後到這個AVF載板材料
基本上這就是什麼
這就是全股池
對比較簡單一點的邏輯是這樣
那這個至少還是可以證明
就是我們不曉得泡沫什麼時候會結束
但至少就目前這幾
這一兩年的狀況來看
台積電的co-works相關的提查
應該都還是會是一個非常好的狀況
給大家一點信心
好就是沒想到連Intel對不對
都加入跟台積電的合作
沒錯
可是台積電確實近期的股價表現比較
沒有到大跌
然後就是一個平穩的狀態
成交量是大幅度的萎縮的
那大幅度萎縮過程中
今天跌破了一個小平台
就2350
所以接下來要守好的平台
就是這個低點
這個低點在2300
那目前來說都還是一個
橫向震盪
所以大家不要說
他今天破季線
今天四條均線全破怎麼辦
他緩到我沒有留意到
他今天破季線
沒有錯
對
所以呢他不用太緊張
因為他是區間震盪
所以區間震盪相型整理的時候
均線不會給你支撐或壓力的效果
所以大家觀察的就是
我反彈這高點的夢果
也就是說你機械站回來
你也不用太開心
你2450突破我們再開心
那你真的要緊張
前低跌破 前低跌破
再來緊張就好了
不過以台電來說
出現這樣的情況的時候
你通常視為是買一點
以台電那麼穩定的
獲利成長狀況來說
然後買了就不要一直看它
因為每天看沒什麼意思
它就長這樣
講得非常的精闢
對 你如果買海機電視
可以刪掉APP的
不然就是一個禮拜載回來一次
好 再來看到大盤的部分
大盤我們昨天說到
這一波行情嚴整M5
那昨天M5跌破
要進行注意可能就是整理的狀態
對 所以今天繼續整理了
那剛好今天越結算
所以整理幅度要稍微
有些超買超買的狀態
好 那不管怎麼樣
我們今天記得
這時日均線跟季線
原本站上的呢
又得負失了
所以又跌破了
那跌破了我們昨天跟大家說
你這一根大量的高低點
可以去留意一下會不會給支撐
那這個地方跌破
所以我們要看的就是這裡
這個地方在這個
4400左右
上下大概加100點
就是這個小區間
那這個小區間
後面還有一個什麼
還有一個月線
所以這也會有個雙重的支撐
我想問我看今天月線
好像變下完了
對 那如果這樣會不會支撐變弱
會 基本上下彎不算支撐
對 但是這幾天扣底下來
它是有機會彎上來的
所以我覺得這邊觀察一下
大量的低點能不能連同月線
給一個支撐的狀態
雖然說不是說拉下影線就是買點
對雖然今天拉下影線
可是今天的影線
我覺得他的力道比較薄弱
如果今天他是紅色的
長這樣 收回開盤價
哎呦 那就很兇
確實是很漂亮
因為整個你拉1000點
對 可是今天這樣子就是
只能知道底部回來的時候
是有人願意去買的
可是你說買到變指點
那我覺得可能要再一兩天的訊號
所以明天如果能夠好一點
結算完 結算壓行情
結算完 如果明天跟紅K
吃掉今天的黑K
那我覺得基本上差不多
就不錯
就不錯了
就可以視為買點
那接下來要挑戰的就是
我們先回五日軍
再來挑戰前高
前高過
那這就是個大恩知情
這就是大家想要的第二隻腳
對 只是有點長短腳
對
長短腳還可以吧
不錯 長短腳比較好
因為修正幅度不大
但目前今天這一根
還沒有止跌訊號
對 我覺得可以再看個一兩天
好吧 對那再來貴買也是一樣
碰季線壓下來
然後來是來到這個
我們昨天有說
就是這邊也是貴買大量的低點
然後有守住
那有守住呢
這邊也碰月線
所以呢也還不錯
但跟大盤一樣
我覺得都是
有人願意接
但還沒有接到
讓他變成是
紙碟的KBUN訊號出現
所以我覺得
上次跟上季都一樣
同步觀察一下
後面如果禮拜四禮拜五有反彈
如果能夠站回五日均線
這個站回來
然後這個站回來
那我覺得就差不多了
應該就可以去找一些好股票
來看一下有沒有低階的機會了
所以我覺得這一波回落
大家不用太緊張
是
那我覺得這一波回落的體感
也不會到
雖然不好
但是也沒有跟之前那樣相比的
體感這麼差
像今天上漲加速還算多的
還是不錯的
所以我覺得大家就不用太恐慌
那也要保持一些信心
等直接需要出現再來重新討好的去
有沒有一些股票可以賣
好 送暖的感覺
是的
所以下一段節目回來的話
我們要聊的叫做公率元件
他們是有所謂的標股基因
那現在可以看得出來
法人大戶投信
有稍微佈局在所謂的被動元件上面
公率元件有沒有呢
其實也有零星機檔是有的
那有這樣的標股基因
又看到我們看到
義法半導體發出了長假
8月下旬要開始長假了
所以你們能夠在這波回檔
重新啟動上工的時候
長假概念股可以回來
有興趣的朋友
可以掃一下艾倫說的QR code
明天早上一樣會發送
公率元件的長報圖給大家
那等一下我們就來聊公率元件
到底看好哪些股票
好 來吧
最近的這個備用元件
上個禮拜稍微反彈一下
那又走路了兩三天
今天被動算蠻厲害的
當然國劇還好啦
可是像什麼
新商店
那個日電帽
金山店這些都漲停板
那其實早上的時候
這個強帽等人也都是開高的
主被動本來今天還不錯
但後來只剩被動
沒錯
所以呢我們
剛剛有看一下形態
我覺得還可以
那當然這兩天又在
有一個題材就是
因為要漲價
這個公立元件
第三波半導體
第三波漲價來了
台賞10月要再漲15%
漲價時成
這邊都幫他準備好了
這個2026年10月的時候
因為他們算後面才漲的
所以到明年搞不好漲價幅度
還可以期待
是的
那目前來說像強貌
這台辦這兩個
但是比較具代表性
然後德維尼克森等等
基本上都是對於他們的產品
要做一個調漲的狀態
那為什麼要漲價呢
首先第一個金上游
對 跟他講一下
像上游的合金這一類的
他們也算是公率半導體
他們是元件類的
上面的金眼類的
那導線架
還有封裝材料同步的走壓
再來供給呢
如果是單純因為要
轉嫁成本的去調漲
那我覺得這個吸引力
稍微低一點點
但你可以發現就是
其實需求是很大
因為供給是供不完的
那我覺得這個就非常有吸引力
目前部分成交的交期
拉長到了52週
那另外整個機櫃
供應率往800服務去做賣進
所以帶動了使用量去增加
也就是說它其實不單純
只是因為AI通膨
而是說它的需求確實也是不錯的
蠻重要的這一點
沒錯
所以這邊是後續可以去注意的
其中一個大題材
那當然這個在7月6月崩盤之前
公立元件已經拉一大段了
那時候講得很誇張
我們全市場都在缺貨
沒錯
但也有人出來說沒有那麼誇張
但還還漲價
跟國外大廠已經發出漲價
還是確定的
是的
所以我覺得這個以漲價題材來講
還是可以稍微注意一下
那這邊基本上都是所謂的公率元件類的
那其實還有很多
包含像是電源管理IC
比如說那個什麼C-Li KY
粒智這個都歸類在裡面
那因為像風車還有什麼
撿命KY
對 然後剛提到吸金原廠
其實這個都是歸類在公率半導體裡面
不過呢 如果以元件類漲價題材來講
那確實是這一些比較主流一點點
那今天可以注意到
全部都撐絲不起
還行啦
就是像今天的盤面
你說疊也疊沒有太多
長也還好
這樣做一個新事
沒有錯
所以這個是一些
一些概念股給大家做參考
那裡面我們當然就要講一些
可能比較代表性的人物了
首先第一個就是台辦
代表性的人物
強貌台辦是一組的
我們講台辦
對
就是常常連在一起
等一下有強貌的人
是
第三波漲價
10月要開跑了
對非合約的客戶要漲價10到15%
那整個算力伺服器的效率非常嚴格
所以對於他們的整個高規格的公率元件來講
是貴 然後亮又大
那再來呢 目前第二季的EPS已經年增
上半年的EPS
半年爆出來了 年增132%
所以有沒有賺錢 有啦
還有在努力賺錢
那只不過
台辦跟強貿過往的股信是真的不太好
對啊
對 但至少前面那一波走勢還算拉得乾脆
對 那這一波修正的幅度也很大
這個都是搖展在下來了
那你可以注意到
搖展下來之後
這裡的行情
就呈現了一個橫向震盪
可是它有多頭
它反彈的不太乾脆
是
而且它反彈的力道
稍微薄弱一點點
跟被動元件這一波
有一點點相似
那我們這邊就稍微注意一下
這個在高檔回落的過程中
其實它還算相對強勢一點點
因為前面長得少
所以疊可能也比較輕
那疊比較輕
後面如果要做一個
資金族群的輪動
我覺得是可以去留意一些相關地位階
這可能這跟宣估有關 跟族群沒有關
那這個公立元件是一個相對位階比較低的
那這邊已經拉出一個恩智形
這兩天有在放量
那唯一比較尷尬
人家在進攻的時候遇到大盤整理
對
就可能情緒沒這麼激情
前面沒跟別人攻
現在要攻了大盤回到
對 因為可能他長在大盤
新聞出來出在大盤要回落的時候
那不過我覺得OK
因為他這邊也願意去有一個新高
剩下就季線突破
這兩天開始放量
只要這兩個大量的高點
都去共同做突破站回季線
其實我覺得這個行情後續
還可以去注意一下
有沒有去往前高做靠攏的一個機會
那這個位階夠低
我覺得停順點也好抓
這邊就可以視為停順
那你如果要拉比較遠
就要拉到前低
但我覺得這個有點太遠了
所以可能這一根紅K
去做跌破
就可以做一個停順的動作
那就看嘛
你這邊已經盤整很久
都沒有跌破嘛
所以跌破就總
我覺得OK
那如果盤整後慢慢的緩墊高
那一個賺賠比的邏輯來看應該還不錯
好 畢竟在下跌之前
公園一切我也聽到很多好消息
是啊 難道好消息就不見了嗎
沒有 所以用風險報酬比來幫大家抓
是 當然也要提醒前面套了的人確實
確實多 蠻多的
那再來另外一個就 聽到了 強帽
他走得好整齊喔
是的 他走成一排牙齒
沒錯 所以整個的狀態來講
都是一個盤整的狀態
那目前盤整呢
當然就是等一個盤整突破囉
那突破要突破什麼
一樣這兩天都有在挑戰
像昨天其實氣勢也很好
但是碰前高
那量有放大
可是沒有過
沒有過就變壓力了
所以呢
對啊沒有過就壓力
昨天買的也套牢了
技術型態好狠喔
沒有辦法
對啊
所以他其實要轉很快
那不過呢
我們就是等這個平台突破
那這個平台剛好兩個大量
所以這個平台突破
基本上季線也就應該要過了
那就會相型整理 又站回季線
那我覺得這個行情
就有機會迎來一波往前高去做
靠近的一個反彈行情
所以我覺得這個都是值得
如果有耐心的這邊可以蹲看看
然後聽說你都很好抓
前低跌破就記得走
所以我覺得這邊都有一些
可以去蹲看看的樣子
再來看到立正 還有誰
立正
比較少聊到他
沒錯 但為什麼會選他
因為我看一下公立元件半導體裡面
他有基本上只有他
是站上季線的
對 你看在台辦強方沒站上
傅鼎也沒站上
就是等於大家很關注那一些
反而形態上要比較辛苦
是 他反而在默默之中在季線上
對 他應該是說他反彈的過程
比較快站回季線
對 那比較快站回季線的過程中
其實他基本面也還可以
五年新高 然後年增率達81%
所以是有在好轉的
當然我覺得如果是以最直接
直接來講的話
應該就前面那兩位
可是如果看型態來講的話
那就立正反而
少數在季線之上的公民元件
我們用型態也偶爾會發現
好奇妙
搞不好這邊的領頭強勢
而且它前面其實那一段
的延續性比較好
如果你大家回去看技術面的話
當然來到這個地方
我們先注意的是
它在季線之上
可是今天這個大量位置
就會是短線
能夠站上再縮
再要不要考慮介入的
因為這邊一個頭
這邊有一個頭
來到這個地方
全部都是壓力區
那壓力區今天想要挑戰
行情不好就失敗
那也就是說呢
你現在想要介入
我們就把這個消化過去
N字型能夠確立的時候
那剛好也是一個大底部的確立
那我覺得到時候
再來重新去做操作就可以
所以呢 季線之上
大概只有他
那可是型態要更好
那我們高點要做突破
那等到做突破
再來做介入
其實我覺得不會太遲
對 所以這邊給大家觀察一下
這幾檔三檔
這個相關的公立元件的個股
好 那附頂長的是像臺辦強帽嗎
長的像強帽
長得像牆帽就是
因為我想富鼎應該滿多神戶朋友
在上面
對
那個也
基本上也是長這樣
就是也都是在這邊很旁邊
好 富鼎長得像這樣
對
所以我覺得那個也可以看
但我想說兩檔指標股之外
叫他就加一個型態好看的
給他做參考
好 有時候也要來一點新鮮貨
忽然說實話
高麗人間的族群不大
講到講去就那幾檔
但是希望藉由教大家
現在有一些指標性的股票
至少以風險報酬比來抓
不會太高
破了前面的低點
你就可能趕快出去
但如果突破了呢
那也許上面他有標股金
就會在網上
好 需要今天節目所有的
圖卡資料的話一樣
歡迎訂閱一下
趙華艾倫說的YouTube頻道
我們會把所有的資料
免費放在首頁進來的天文欄